en estas imágenes de la televisión de
burkina pasó los soldados acogen a 62
mujeres y cuatro bebés Estas mujeres
burkinesas acaban de ser liberadas tras
ser secuestradas por presuntos yadistas
ya están libres tras ocho largos días en
manos de sus capturas con Claridad
las víctimas eran interrogadas por el
ejército que Investiga la identidad de
los secuestradores el jueves y el
viernes pasados Estas mujeres fueron
raptadas en los alrededores de ardinda
en el sahel la región bloqueada por las
tropas yihadistas habían salido de su
pueblo para conseguir comida esta
burkinesa estaba entre ellas y había
logrado escapar
conseguí escapar con mi hija
las demás no podían porque estaban
aterrorizadas las víctimas fueron
encontradas a 200 kilómetros al sur de
su pueblo la radio televisión de burkina
habló de una operación de las fuerzas
armadas Sin dar más detalles aunque la
magnitud del secuestro la ong no ocultan
su preocupación se imprimir Es la
primera vez que asistimos a un secuestro
de varias decenas de mujeres es una
situación Nueva Hoy en día en términos
de inseguridad que hay que tener en
cuenta
cerca de un millón de personas viven
actualmente en zonas bloqueadas por los
yihadistas en burkina faso desde 2015 el
país se ha enfrentado a crecientes
ataques de grupos vinculados a al qaida
y al estado islámico